why do you refuse to vote well there's
an
essay about that that see this is
exactly why i did the book so when
people are like why do you refuse to
vote i'll be like just buy the book
uh but basically the premise is uh um
uh you know there's a few slogans don't
vote it only encourages them but also i
do not
think that if you if i would vote uh
i would have a right to complain because
if i'm
hiring a lawyer and that lawyer i'm
saying speaks for me you know this
person represents me if i'm hiring an
accountant this person
you know i'm outsourcing i am
voluntarily granting them authority
if i go and say i want this person to be
my representative
and they do they change their word which
they will inevitably do
i brother i asked for it i said i want
this person to represent me and i do not
believe any politician
does or can represent me so it's
avoiding being complicit in the game
yeah and it also i first of all it's
just a waste of time
so in terms of like ways to use your
time if you want to make the world a
better place
there's old people who are lonely
there's a dog you can foster
there's kids who don't have a dad who
you can mentor there's so many different
ways where if you want to work for the
common good and make society a better
place
if you just commit that one hour you
actually feed someone who's hungry buy
some
work for an hour and buy a poor person
clothing there's just infinite ways
that we could all marginally increase
the uh happiness you know
in the world around us so voting is a
ritual that validates
those who slaughter you know hundreds of
thousands of people in the name of
uh patriotism and things like this so
it's it's a
uh a you know not a fan of democracy to
put it mildly
how do you feel then in the build-up to
an election when obviously you get asked
a lot i've asked you on this show
ideas and insights around the election
is that
does that feel a little bit like playing
somebody else's games it feel a bit like
oh god i just can't be bothered to
even discuss this arcade institution
not at all it's it's the opposite it's
that it's i'm being able to discuss it
without the facade that this is some
kind of noble endeavor and
you've got no agenda i do i do have an
agenda which is the destruction of the
state
um but it's also uh just exposing the
manipulations and machinations
of the parties the corporate media
social media and all these other various
uh figures so it's
it's it's it is of great interest and
and you know
to watch how this sociologically plays
out
even though i don't regard any of it as
uh valid thank you very much for tuning
in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
makes me very happy peace
you